je fais partie des observateurs en tout
cas de la vie politique notamment à
droite qui pensent qu'il peut être c'est
très différent de ce qu'on vient
d'entendre mais je pense qu'il ya pas eu
de zemmour isation des esprits mais que
les esprits étaient et morizet avant
eric zemmour et qui se sont reconnus une
partie des français s'est reconnu dans
le constat que faisait eric zemmour
comme journaliste et que fait
aujourd'hui eric zemmour comme candidat
à la présidence aujourd'hui on voulait
donc montré des différences trop eric
zemmour et marine le pen est ce que pour
vous eric zemmour et est à droite de
marine le pen vous pouvez mettre le
découvre est-ce qu'il est à droite de
maryse les plus que marine le pen ou est
ce qu'il est ça va dépendre des sujets
allant du pont de sully oui ça va bien
sûr dépendre des sujets ça va être un
peu l'objet d'ailleurs de cet échange
voilà de savoir ce qui distingue
vraiment eric zemmour de marine le pen
et parce que évidemment il ya des gens
probablement qu'ils regardent ce soir la
télévision qui sont sans doute d'accord
avec eric zemmour qui était peut être
d'accord avec eric zemmour journaliste
et qui se pose aujourd'hui la question
de savoir pour qui ils vont voter vous
avez dit à villepinte eric zemmour que
vous vouliez protéger les électeurs
aient l'air de la trahison et que vous
voulez rendre le droit de vote aux
électeurs du front national alors il ya
deux choix il ya valérie pécresse qui
affirme en tout cas les gens qui sont
autour d'elle qui affirme qu' elle n'a à
peu près rien en commun avec vous alors
on verra pour ses électeurs ils
choisiront eux-mêmes un homme à tort et
marine le pen marine le pen en revanche
a expliqué que vous n'étiez ni un
adversaire ni un partenaire mais un
concurrent alors on va essayer de savoir
justement sur quoi vous pouvez
concurrence est aujourd'hui marine le
pen alors je vais passer sur par exemple
parce sanitaire la privatisation de
l'audiovisuel public la limitation d
attribution des aides sociales aux
français seulement parce que vous êtes
d'accord là dessus avec elle ça on le
sait alors on va commencer par
l'immigration qui est un sujet qui vous
tient à coeur et qui est évidemment un
marqueur de marine le pen elle elle
souhaite inscrire et je la cite dans la
constitution la maîtrise de
l'immigration la priorité nationale et
la supériorité du droit français sur le
droit international via un référendum
évidemment pour contester enfin pour
justement que ça ne soit pas contestée
par les juges est-ce que c'est également
votre méthode et sur quoi vous
différenciez vous sur ce point essentiel
de marine le pen jeu je ne crois pas
utile de mettre dans la constitution la
maîtrise de l'immigration
la constitution c'est vraiment les
rapports entre les pouvoirs publics
contre le gouvernement l'assemblée etc
il faut arrêter de surcharger cette
constitution en revanche
je serais d'accord sur un point avec
elle c'est cette histoire de droit
national et de droit européen et de
droit international moi je
n'ai pas la même méthode mais l'objectif
est le même c'est à dire que je veux que
le parlement reprennent la main et le
pouvoir et donc je proposerai une
réforme constitutionnelle du de
l'article 55 qui prévoit que les traités
sont supérieurs à la loi et qui ont
permis au juge de
le juger et 2 et 2,2
d'annuler une loi qui était contraire à
un traité selon eux donc moi je ferai
une ré temps passionnel qui dira que la
loi postérieure est supérieur au traité
hier la loi et sa ressuscite si j'ose
dire une vieille thèse juridique
française qui était celle du conseil
d'état jusqu'en 1989 avec l'arrêt
nicouleau et qu'ils disaient c'était la
théorie de la loi écran c'est à dire que
le juge s'interdisait de juger une loi
je pense qu'il faut revenir à 7 cette
méthode maintenant pour l'immigration
toutes les mesures que j'ai donné tout à
l'heure face à monsieur caron je les
mettrai dans un référendum pour
que les français décident s'ils sont
pour ces mesures nous contre ces mesures
alors et parce que sinon le conseil
constitionnel
en fonction de sa jurisprudence les
dénonceraient les annulerait et donc moi
je veux que le peuple français puisse
s'exprimer parce que face à un
référendum le conseil constitionnel ne
peut rien dire selon sa jurisprudence de
1962 on va parler de la jeunesse
maintenant charlotte je crois alors sur
la question de la jeunesse qui écoute
beaucoup cette émission alors marine le
pen j'ai pris deux exemples quelques
elle proposait la gratuité totale des
trains aux heures creuses pour les 18 25
ans et la suppression pendant 5 ou 2 2
pendant cinq ans par don de l'impôt sur
le revenu pour les personnes de moins de
30 ans alors que vous inspirent ces
décisions de marine le pen est calé vous
votre manière de capter l'attention de
la jeunesse a je pense qu'à me bats paix
sera content ne pas payer d'impôts eux
c'est un bon exemple bah oui c'est un
bon exemple au liban il a moins de 30
ans que ça
va faire un petit ayew
ça serait intéressant
d'ailleurs donc
je sais je n'aime pas les mesures de
gratuité je pense que ce n'est pas
responsabilisant je suis contre la
gratuité en général on donne la gratuité
aux clandestins aussi je pense que ce
n'est pas une bonne mesure il faut que
les gens soient responsables
maintenant évidemment il faut aider les
plus jeunes ils sont ils ont beaucoup
souffert là pendant le confinement il
faut évidemment les aider je jeu
on peut proposer des mesures j'avais
proposé mois des mesures pour les jeunes
qui voulaient s'installer acheter un
appartement je proposais parce que le
prix de l'immobilier a augmenté
considérablement
je proposais la suppression des droits
de mutation vous savez c'est les rois
les les fameux spread notaire pardon qui
s'élève quand même à des sommes
importantes pour tous les gens qui qui
sont à 7 à 8% pour tous les gens qui
achetaient un appartement les primo
accédants jusqu'à 250 mille euros ça
leur fait une économie de 15000 euros ça
c'est une mesure pour les les gens les
jeunes en général pas les moins de 30
ans
voilà je pense qu'on a effectivement des
mesures différentes mais c'est
nécessaire elle comme moi évidemment on
fait attention à toute cette jeunesse en
particulier les jeunes les plus pauvres
qui sont qui sont terriblement appauvris
par la situation économique française
alors éric petite parenthèse sur le
dernier sondage qui est sorti hier soir
vous êtes crédité de 15 % d'intentions
de vote pour monter de 2 2 points marine
le pen est crédité de 16% est ce que
vous dites qu'il pourra en rester qu'un
an ou deux à bas au second tour il en
restera classé surnommé là donc ça si on
est tous les deux au second tour elle
est aussi très belle vous savez qui est
là tout est possible oui mais oui oui
ton bien sûr tout est possible mais
j'avais vu honnêtement 15 16 17 et 20 c
la marge d'erreur c'est ça non mais ce
secteur on est à égalité qu'est ce que
vous pensez qu'un la gauche est très
loin derrière jae-in et la gagne d'algos
derrière 4% aller dans les travaux
allaient dans les travaux
juste eric eric zemmour est ce que vous
pensez qu à un moment tu as on sait ce
que tout le monde se dit je pense que
charlotte sera d'accord avec moi un
moment on se dit il y en a un qui va
prendre le pas sur les canaux mossawa
bascule il y en a un qui m'a passé on
pense à 20 22 et l'autre va descendre à
11,12 est ce que vous pouvez faire ce
que vous pensez être celui qui va
prendre le pas sur marine le pen parce
que c'est sûr qu'il va en avoir un des
deux à un moment je vous dis je vous
êtes à 15,16 tous les deux c'est votre
analyse est bonne elle mériterait
d'après moi d'être complété il faut
mettre dans votre analyse valérie
pécresse bien sûr pas d'équipé très
douces en fait c'est un jeu à trois en
plus c est
donc c'est un jeu à trois j'ai pensé
vous dites que vous êtes vous voulez
suivre la lignée du rpr absolue valérie
pécresse aussi non valérie pécresse est
une centriste oui mais valérie pécresse
est une centriste ac non mais c'est ces
macro valérie bénard aleri pécresse vous
allez voir attendait sa campagne elle va
aller non non non cotées elles vaillant
nouveaux repères si oui sur boulzane
aussi l'amour mais oui bien sûr elle va
pas rester au centre des chaussées
rez-de-chaussée aussi dans madame
pécresse fera exactement comme chirac
c'est-à-dire qu'elle estimera que les
promesses n'engagent que ceux qui les
écoutent et donc elle trahit enfin les
lecteurs ça marcherait pas un match à
trois et madame pécresse vous savez il y
à une quelques années puisqu'on toujours
mes textes elle madame pécresse a signé
une tribune avec rokhaya diallo à la
gloire du multiculturalisme et de la
diversité madame pécresse donc si vous
voulez pour moi est profondément une
centriste et c'est profondément une
chiraquienne qui comme tous les
chiraquiens préfère les places aux
convictions et qui donc trahir à ses
électeurs moi ce que je pense pourquoi
je pense que je suis le mieux placé des
trois je vais vous expliquer et nous et
je vais très simple important eu en fait
madame le pen a un électorat eux
massivement des classes populaires
qui n'en qui ne prend aucune voix à
l'électorat et l'eire qui est plus
bourgeoise est plus aisé plus diplômés
en général et plus retraités et pluvieux
de l'autre côté madame pécresse a un
électorat le reste de l'électorat fillon
parce qu'elle n'a pas tout l'électorat
fillon vous allez voir pourquoi c'est à
cause de moi
c'est que elle a un électorat justement
que n'a pas madame le pen âgé csp + et
plus embourgeoisé plus aisés et au
milieu
moi j'ai un électorat justement des deux
côtés c'est à dire que j'ai un électorat
populaire qui vient de chez madame le
pen à peu près 33 % à 30 % et j'ai un
électorat de gens plus aisés plus csp +
plus âgés qui vient de monsieur fillon
en 1900 2010 est à peu près 30% et j'ai
à peu près 30% de d'anciens agents
sionistes bien sûr ce que je pense ce
quoi je pense c'est que je vais
continuer à grandir avec les deux est ce
que je pense c'est que je suis le seul
qui fasse la synthèse entre ces deux
électorats c'est à dire c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit à villepinte que je veux
rendre le droit de vote aux électeurs du
front national parce que les électeurs
du front national n'ont plus le droit de
vote alors puisque madame le pen perd
tout le temps alors il est donc qu'elle
est condamnée à perdre jusqu'à elle n'a
pas l'électorat de madame plan
d'ajustement et madame p et ebs et
madame pécresse attendez je finis et
madame pécresse si je n'étais pas là si
je n'étais pas là si je n'avais pas été
là prix elle n'avait aucune chance
d'être au sujet justement c'est la
question c'est la question que je vous
connais pas ce que vont revenir là
dessus
l'argument de barrières ipcress on va
revenir sur deux points l'argument de
léry pécresse sait je suis la seule à
pouvoir battre le président sortant
c'est vrai que dans les sondages un
sondage on le voit oui un sondage qui la
donnent à 52,48 absolu et c'est
maintenant vraiment une leçon c'est
normal ans passés dans la seule à
pouvoir est normal
de l'autre côté vous parlais justement
de valérie pécresse qui serait si vous
n'étiez pas là on sait qu elle serait
troisième le monde largement troisième
distancé par marine le pen a exactement
justement ma question elle importante
est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il va y
avoir les républicains et
la république en marche qui vont tout
faire pour que vous n'ayez pas vos 500
signatures pour vous éliminer
si j'arrête le problème avec les vous
avez raison mais si les républicains
font cette bêtise tactique
madame le pen sera à 25 mai m'a dit
madame pécresse ne sera pas au second
tour donc oui mais et et la république
en marche c'est
là avaient intérêt à se retrouver face à
marine le pen absolument on est d'accord
mais la république quand j'en sais qu'il
ya des pressions n'apparaît que bébé
mariton bugarach ne peut rien bloquer
puisqu'elle n'a pas début tant qu'elle
n'a pas de maire donc elle ne peut rien
donner on n'est plus temps au temps au
temps n'est plus au temps de bastia
d'intérêt qui disait donné tant de temps
de parrainage a déclaré acquis en plus
jeunes au sénat scandale démocratique
d'ailleurs alors s'ils subissent des
pressions csssae communauté de communes
des déclarations et s'est entraîné mais
c'est scandaleux c'est le gouvernement
monsieur hollande vous en êtes où de rio
il n'y a pas que sa double de scandaleux
on est d'accord sur land surtout juste
eric zemmour vous pensez vous allez
d'avoir osé signer parce que c'est la
seule chose dont tout le monde se pose
combien là on est à trois cents 300 ch
est pas facile c'est pas facile c'est ça
non parce que je n'ai pas d'appareil
partisan je n'ai pas d'appareil au
d'élus donc c'est très difficile mais je
n'ai sollicité mère je pense que c'est
un devoir démocratique de leur part je
vous dire d'un autre côté ce que vous
pensez pas si c'est ce que je moi je ne
disais parfois ce que vous pensez pas
justement que les républicains vont
essayer de pousser pour que justement
des mères vous donnent leurs signatures
parce qu'ils auront la chance était
malin tactiquement c'est ce qu'il ferait